yeah when people find out what
profession I'm in and they look at me
like oh you poor thing like they feel
sorry for me don't feel sorry for me my
profession is no different than the
brain surgeon you know I wake up every
day and I go to work and I choose to do
this just like he wakes up every day and
chooses to continue to be a brain
surgeon I choose to continue to
prostitute
it's nothing to feel sorry for me over
or uh Tasha
Tasha where are you from originally
originally I'm from Fayetteville
Arkansas hmm tell me about your family
growing up oh well it wasn't your
typical family from the Midwest there
wasn't you know white big offense or
anything like that my father was abusive
my mother was a cocktail waitress in a
bar for many years
so early on in life
I came up in a bar if that makes any
sense you know after she left my dad
literally in the middle of the night she
I remember her wrapping me in a blanket
it was storming outside and we just took
off and that was that was it she moved
us to a
housing project
um
that was god-awful lots of rodents and
bugs and
that's just that's that's where it all
started Applegate how would you describe
your childhood uh fairly I mean aside
from being you know not having a lot of
money and it's just you know single
parent single-payer at home after my mom
left my dad it was fairly happy um spent
a lot of time with my grandparents but
um
you know when I was with my mom it was
it was a struggle I mean we out every
day to survive
you know she worked two jobs
um and I didn't find out until later in
life she was also prostituting
on the side yeah
I found that out once I was an adult and
had actually got into the game myself
and then found out you know that she had
also
had her way with that as well so how did
you first get introduced to the game
um
I kind of got Bamboozled really
um I think I think every girl does I I
met a guy I don't want to leave names
out I don't want to you know get anybody
in any trouble or anything like that but
I met a guy and he actually asked me to
move some dope for him sell some dope
and so that's initially you know how I
got started come to find out
few months in he's a pimp
and we've gone out of town supposed to
be going on a run you know to pick up
some to pick up some dope and uh
how he didn't have money for a hotel
room I don't know
or if that was just you know the story
he gave me but he put me in a position
where it was like okay uh this is what
you're gonna do
um you're gonna go out here and you're
gonna sell some [__] and we're gonna
get the room you know and then you know
do what we need to do and go back
tomorrow you know go back home tomorrow
and this was in Dallas Fort Worth so
I'm in Dallas I don't know anybody and
this guy that I've trusted for you know
several months now moving all this dope
for him is telling me I have to do what
okay uh
and uh you know it threatened me a few
times and because I wasn't going at
first that was real uncomfortable with
it um
kind of emotional
but uh
you know a person can only threaten your
life so many times you know I'm Gonna
Leave You the trunk of a car in the
middle of Dallas nobody will ever find
you nobody will miss you kind of thing
and so I
turn my first trick that that night
500 bucks probably the easiest and the
hardest 500 I've ever made in my life
and then it was kind of like I was
locked in you were called that was it I
mean 21 21 and I'm 41 now so you know 20
years
20 years I've been doing this
um but yeah I was locked in at that
point and nobody nobody told me okay if
you do this there's no way out
you know if you do this you're stuck for
life you know
and that just started a long
a long list of a long laundry list of
just [__]
you know it's uh but survival I just
struggling to survive
that's how I got the scar on my face and
that actually is
fairly recent
yeah
a pimp and a hoe
he held me down and she cut my face I
where'd this happen this actually
happened in my hometown
um been home for a few for about three
months
and um you know business was slow it's
small town America you know you get
business but it's not much money and um
does this game operate in every yeah
large and small it does it really really
does it's so under the radar for sure
yeah so many people yeah except on
Figueroa Street it's pretty under the
radar well it even and even where I'm
from in Fayetteville you know that you
wouldn't you could be sitting in a room
full of hoes and not know it
you know they use a website I skip the
games and we post
um you know post photos and a little ad
that says you know you're like hey guys
if you're looking for some fun type [__]
and then they call you on your usually
we use like a text now number or
something like that call you on your
number and normally if you if you have a
pimp
um that's who they're talking to they
don't know that they think they're
talking to you so a lot of girls on
Instagram that are doing that set it all
up and then you know the next thing you
know you're getting picked up or meeting
somebody at a hotel or whatnot
um
and it's weird because like on these
websites there's like a menu you know if
you want a quick visit or half an hour
hour or whatever and then there's like a
menu of services that you perform and
guys just go on there and they pick you
out and they pick out what they want and
they text the number and
you set up the meat
um but yeah even even in small town
America Midwest
Bible Belt it's happening
it's happening
a lot
met a lot of good people but I
descended this particular individual
um
we were actually in a relationship I
suppose you could say and had been
for about a year a little over a year
and uh there was four other girls you
know other than myself that that he was
putting out there and me being the
oldest and having been with him the
longest out of all five of us I made the
most money and that causes jealousy I
mean that just that's
it causes a lot of friction especially
when the girls like
whoever you know your pimp is or whatnot
and
he was an attractive attractive guy you
know and one of the younger girls she
had actually just she's only been with
us about three weeks she just she didn't
like me we had vomited a lot and he left
me in charge of these [__] you know
keep them in line make sure that they're
going to calls and whatnot because like
I said after I was telling you when I
got here after you know years of doing
this I've developed a few health health
issues my legs swell a lot if I'm on my
feet too much so
um
it was kind of like I was a right hand
to him you know with these younger with
this new generation coming in and uh
she went to him I was gone out on a play
and she went to him and and bitched and
complained and I hurt her feelings and I
guess he was a little sweet on her too
and um
for whatever reason
she didn't want to have to work with me
anymore and so
I came in for making my play and he was
waiting kind of behind there's like a
came into a four-year and when I opened
the door he was back behind the door and
I walked around you know the side of the
door and turned to close it and when I
went to close it he grabbed me from
behind
and just had like had my arms like this
you know and just and immobilized me and
she just got on my face and was just
screaming at me
um that she was gonna take me out of the
game
um she didn't want to deal with me
anymore and he was totally with it and
next thing I know I like I hear I heard
a loud crash and what it was she took a
beer bottle and she hit me right here
with it
and um
you know cut my head open up here and
then she took the broken piece of the
bottle that was left in her hand and
just stab me in my face just rip my face
open
and
they just left me there
laying on the floor
um
I really didn't know what was going on
you know I didn't know what I'd done
to deserve that
and I wasn't really I mean I knew I was
I knew I was hurt I knew that you know I
was injured or whatnot I didn't know how
bad my face was laid open probably a
good three inches from here to here
um
and um
I'm sorry
that kind of betrayal is is it's tough
it's part of the game though it is it is
and people can they turn on you in an
instant
at any moment you know you always have
to you know watch your back and make
sure that you you can protect yourself
you don't have any friends you have no
friends and there is no trust and that's
a hard lesson to learn
um and I knew that you know it's like I
tell many girls since this happened
don't ever let anybody catch you
slipping you know
because they can take your life in in an
instant and that was that was I don't
know if that was the plan that night or
if she just wanted to permanently
disfigure me or or what they what what
it is she wanted to do but
um
I laid there by probably a good 30 45
minutes and then one of the other girls
came into the house they took off like
after they did this they just the two of
them just took off
one of the other girls came in and I was
covered in blood and I was just in and
out of Consciousness and um she picked
me up and she's like I'm gonna take you
to the hospital and
um
she was as Brave as she could be
she started knocking on doors you know
we didn't know anybody
where we were at and she started
knocking on doors and this woman said
she would take us to the you know the
nearest Urgent Care and it was downtown
um probably about it's like three in the
morning
you know like I said small town America
um
we get to the Urgent Care and of course
police meet us there
and they want me to talk to him and tell
them what happened you know I refuse to
talk I'm not I'm not a rat not you know
I'm gonna give everybody give anybody up
and uh
got my face sewed up and whatnot and
then the first time I saw it they didn't
want me to look at it at the hospital it
was pretty gnarly the first time I saw
it
I passed out like I walked into the
bathroom I was getting ready to leave
the hospital I walked into the bathroom
and flipped the light on and it was just
like I didn't have any idea who was
staring back at me
I had a knot on my head that probably
stuck out two inches
starting to turn colors already you know
Brews and everything and then just this
life-changing
life-changing uh
gash across my face 19 stitches down my
cheek and I've had two surgeries since
then I went to jail not long after this
happened probably about a month after it
happened I got picked up on some
warrants
um and uh I saw stitches in my face and
so in County Jail I have to go you know
I had surgery two times while I was in
County Jail
um and that's no place you don't want to
be locked up in any kind of facility
whether it be County or state or
anything like Federal whatever and be
ill or have to have some you know they
treat they don't treat you any better
than a dog
and um
had two surgeries in shackles
to try and you know get there was still
glass in my face I almost lost my eye
you had free floating glass here on my
cheekbone and everything and I haven't
seen either one of them since
it's uh but I did if I ever do I promise
you I'll get my lick back
most definitely I mean that's it's all
part of the game right did that did that
change your attitude about it are you oh
immensely
um but you're still doing it
yeah like I said even if you want out or
make plans to get out you don't you
you're not getting out it's just I mean
you get addicted to the hustle you get
addicted to the fast money it's not
necessarily it's not it's not about the
sex anymore it's about
that paycheck was it ever about the sex
um
or is it all always about money
it's all the primary focus has always
been money always let me ask you this is
an important question do you are drugs a
part of your life they were
they were
um and you know
is that what got you in the first place
that's what made it easier
that's what I think that's what make
that's what
that's what got me on drugs really
honestly
um because it made it easier if I was
high if you know if I'm high I don't
have to
I don't have to think about what I'm
doing you know and um what was your drug
initially my drug of choice were benzos
like Xanax and Klonopin you know I was
at one point at the height of my benzo
addiction which I still I still um
still use benzos I was probably snorting
like five six bars a day
and you know I don't know if you're
familiar but you know we mix that with
alcohol and you wake up tomorrow and you
don't remember what happened yesterday
so you know that makes it even easier to
go out and do this [__] and then
um I finally at some point probably
five years in
I started using meth and that was
something I swore I would never do
because my mom was an addict and that it
just swallowed her up and eventually
ultimately that's why she's not with
with us anymore she passed away nine
years ago
sir
uh
and that was tough to deal with I was
actually in Phoenix Arizona when she
died
and um
couldn't get home you know
had the money to get home but work was
more work was more important and and I
let that I let that
take control of everything
you get addicted to the money mostly
and then the drug addiction comes into
into play and then that becomes really
important too because if I don't have my
meth or if I don't have my my my pills
like I can't do this I can't go to work
I can't
go out here and you know
[__] five people today for fifteen
hundred dollars like it's it's you just
can't do it you can't
um and I do still use mess from time to
time but not as often as I used to I'm
just really
I have five kids you know
um
and
who's raising them their dads
yeah my oldest one he's actually he's
20. so he's on his own and I've got a 14
year old daughter an 11 year old
daughter an eight a nine-year-old son
and eight year old son
and the last thing I would ever want is
for my girls
to get involved you know in a life like
this so
um in 2018
I have
my life was spinning out of absolutely
out of control that's probably at the
height of my meth addiction and
um
I lost our home
and I called her dad you know she's
working locally at that point and I
called their dad and my my the father my
three middle children the two girls and
my nine-year-old son and it's like I
told him I said you gotta you gotta come
get them you know and it family and
friends have speculated for a long time
that I was doing this but it's not
something that it's like the it's like
the elephant in the room but it's the
skeleton in the closet you know it's
like everybody speculates or everybody
thinks they know but this is something
we don't talk about you know and that
was the first time that I actually like
admitted to anybody
um
that this is what I was doing that I was
prostituting and I let their dad know
that you know this is what life is life
is now and your husband knew
um no this is my it was at this point he
was an ex and um
he didn't know
and that was the first time that I just
admitted to any kind of family member
you know that this is what I was
involved in and he showed up probably
two hours later and picked up my
children and he's had him since then
um I see him probably once a year
in the summer you know they got out of
school for the summer
um
it's real hard it's real hard because
you know as my children and I are very
close
and uh
now it's like their dad doesn't want to
even that one time a year he doesn't
really want to send them to me because
he knows he knows what I'm doing
you know that you know
how I make my money and he doesn't want
my children
to witness anything crazy and he doesn't
you know he doesn't want our girls to to
grow up to be prostitutes who who does
nobody says when they're a kid you know
they ask you what do you want to be when
you grow up nobody says I want to be a
prostitute nobody says I want to be you
know a drug dealer
and it just or in circumstances kind of
push us in different
you walked in your mom's footsteps
though yeah did you see her doing it
when you were a kid no
no
I mean I saw men come around
and there for a while probably
um I'll say I was about seven or eight
years old for about three years I was
about seven when I started noticing that
uh and lack of a better way to put it
there was a revolving door in our home
of different guys but it was like the
same you know same five or six
men would come what is it that's
constantly from quitting
the money
I mean what you tell me what job I can
go out here and get with nothing but a
high school education
and make
you know three grand today
there's not one
cash money right now you know even
though I don't have my kids they don't
want for anything
you give a lot of money to your kids as
much as I can yeah yeah
I'd say a good a good portion of my
money goes to my children
and into a pimp as well oh yeah he gets
his off the top
um you know you coming you go out here
and you you make a play for 500 as soon
as you're as soon as you hit the door
where he's at or back in the car or
whatever it
hand it all over and then he will give
back what he feels like I deserve can
you do this without a pimp absolutely
absolutely
um you know and I've gone Renegade a few
times and just you know done done it by
myself but for whatever reason I just
feel like it's a lot easier
with somebody there to you know set the
play up and all I have to do is get
dressed
throw on some makeup and head out the
door
you know and then that's security too
to have a pimp this just to know there's
somebody that if anything goes wrong
there's somebody there that's gonna
that's gonna have your back sort of
but I've never had anything go wrong
thus far with not with with a customer
or anything like that yeah you've done
this in other cities you've done Dallas
and yeah of Dallas um I've gone to
Orlando
um out here uh
those are probably the biggest cities
I've been to
um I've been out here well this this
trip I've been out here just about a
week now
um this is my third time to come out to
LA
what do you think people don't
understand about girls that do this kind
of work
they don't understand everybody has a
story you know there's a there's
something that puts you there in that
position it's not something that you
just like I said you don't wake up one
day and say oh I'm gonna be a prostitute
today
you know there's something that that led
you down that road that puts you in a
position to feel like that was there was
no way out or there's something you had
to do
whether it be because you were about to
lose your home or your car or you are
homeless on the street or you know
whatever whatever your story is
everybody's got a backstory there's
reason why that we're in this business
but at the end of the day we're still
just like you
we're just like anybody else out here
trying to survive make a buck make sure
that you know we have a warm bed to
sleep in and and
food in our belly you know tell me about
your father
oh wow
my dad um my biological father he was
that's a real piece of work
he was real abusive
um with my mother I remember you know he
as a child he just beat the living [__]
out of my mother and when she got a
chance to get away you know during one
of these beating she'd just get up and
run and I remember seeing her like run
out of front door of our house so many
times and
um just jump in her car and she'd be
gone just for days and he'd tell me
horrible stories like that he'd
for a whole week I thought my mother was
dead
she had told me she took off he beat her
up one night and she took off and she
was gone for for days and I kept asking
from you know I want my mom and he's
like well I killed her and chopped her
up in little pieces and put her in the
basement
so for about a week I got him under the
impression that my mother is dead and
she's in our basement
and he to keep me out of the basement he
told me that there was
a [__] in the basement that had sharp
pointy teeth and that would you know eat
me alive if I even touched the door so
I'm thinking that
this little person is in our in our
basement
feasting on my mother's body parts
um
you know that's PTSD is real and things
like that really damage a person you
know and then when she comes walking in
the door a week later it's kind of like
well
how do you put those pieces together I
thought she was dead you know
and this went on for
until she left him
it was just a constant almost every day
like she was getting her ass whooped
almost every day
for nothing like little [__] you know
um he'd ask her for something to drink
and she didn't bring it quick enough so
that got her an ass woman or you know he
come in from work and the bed's not made
or the floor's not mopped or just
anything he would come with any excuse
any excuse to put his hands on her
and uh
when I was
six I want to say
maybe five five or six she was when she
finally finally left him and she was by
herself it was just me and her for a
while and that's when I started noticing
you know that revolving door but you
know the same five men came through all
the time
and sometimes all of them in one day but
at that age you don't
you don't put two and two together to
know that you know okay something's not
right or you know my mom's doing
something something strange for a little
piece of change
but uh it definitely makes an impact
otherwise I don't think I would have
followed in her footsteps
um
it wasn't intentional
it was kind of like a
again survival you know
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I would have made better choices
obviously a lot better choices
um I probably would have went to college
um made better friends and you know it's
it's the people that I chose to surround
myself with is is what got me
in the position I'm in today
uh
yeah I would have made better choices
gone to school further my education and
you know stayed in school
I probably I'm sure that would have kept
me out of the street
what's your biggest fear now because
you're not young in the game you're
I made it fair later end of your right
marketability and that's the thing you
know you can't do this forever you're
still beautiful I'm shocked that you're
41 but thank you thank you but you know
eventually I I won't be able to do this
anymore you'll age out eventually yeah
and that's scary because then what am I
gonna do
like I said I have a high school
education and once I'm too old to do
this
I don't I don't have a work history to
go down the you know even the local gas
station and apply for a job I have no
work history what the [__] am I gonna
put on the application
I've been hoeing for the last 20 years
you know come on
so that's my that's my biggest fear just
is is when that day comes and I can't do
this anymore what am I going to do to
survive
well how am I going to take care of my
kids
how am I gonna you know
they can't put money money back for
their college education once I'm out of
this business
and then my you know second biggest fear
is
um
death
which is always a possibility with this
game every every day every day every
time that phone rings
and it's it's a play and every time I
ever every time I leave the hotel room
or wherever I'm staying at to go make
this money that's a possibility it's a
very real possibility that I won't come
back
tell me about the kind of guys who are
your customers
um Now That I'm Older uh
and I've I've learned a few things as
far as like screening you know screening
customers they're businessmen
for the most part gentlemen I mean I
don't really you know these guys most of
them are married
and have families and if it were to get
out that they were out here buying [__]
like that would be just life ending for
them that would that would ruin their
their marriages and their careers and so
it's real discreet
they pay better
a lot better that's nice absolutely that
just means the better they pay the less
work I have to do later you know I'm
saying that it's like oh maybe you only
have to turn you know go out
three plays today you know but what's
the sweetest relationship you've had
money-wise the sweetest
um and this is current actually I have
in I have a little a little guy from
from New Orleans
um
and he just he's about five foot two and
just as countries can be but he's sweet
as apple pie and we do absolutely
anything for me
um and he's actually you know try to get
me away from this a few times it's like
I told him it's unrealistic for him to
think that I you know this I'm this is
not pretty woman
you know you can't just buy me out of
the game and but he's he's sweet you
know I've called him a few times since
I've been out here and just been like
you know hey
you know send me some money how much
money is he send your way a few hundred
you know two three hundred just whatever
I asked for I tried to overdo it because
he's very generous
but um
yeah he's he's
a sweetheart
and you're saying you're staying in
motels now yeah yeah and if I really
wanted it if I really wanted to leave
this alone like that would be the guy
that I could call and say okay
you know but I mean
at some point he's gonna die
like I said he's when I say he's older
he's in his 70s 60s 70s something like
that oh really yeah yeah so that doesn't
to me when I look at that that doesn't
seem like stability to me because
he can die tomorrow and then I don't
have that money
and then I'm right back doing this
anyway so
I might as well just keep doing what I'm
doing this is a lonely life for you
yeah because you you can't trust anybody
nobody's really your friend
um that's got to be hard yeah it's it's
Cutthroat you know they'll pretend to be
your friend and
make you real comfortable and then rob
you
or you know like some of these girls the
younger girls especially
um they like to they like to play dirty
you know they'll that still plays from
you and
it's hard to be surrounded by Hustlers
and snakes all day every day and it just
it just the way that you have to be when
you're around these people it's almost
like you gotta wear a mask you know
um
When in Rome do like the Romans do right
I'm not a shady person but
yeah I could be just as grimy as the
next person it's the next [__]
out here just as grimy how do you think
the streets have changed you
uh
on a human on a more human level I don't
have a whole lot of I don't have a lot
of patience for people
um I don't I don't have a lot of
patience to listen to Somebody's sob
story because you know what whatever
you're struggling with today I've
probably been there done that
and struggle
with other things that are much far
worse than what anybody could really
tell me about their life I just I don't
really
people don't interest me much anymore
building lasting relationships with
people just seems ridiculous to me
because
at any moment anybody can switch up on
you and take everything you've got
so I don't really
I don't know if you'd say I choose to be
lonely or if I choose to not have
friends out of I guess out of fear that
you know one day they're going to switch
up on me anyways
so what's the point of having friends
I'm married to the game like that that's
my friend
Do You Believe In Love
not anymore no no
no
even even like your
a square marriage of 20 years you still
see that as an arrangement
for myself oh no it's like a a woman who
is married to her husband for 20 years
is it still a financial trade of I would
think so I mean the man is providing
versus the woman yeah and she mostly I
look at I look at women like they marry
to be taken care of I mean why else
would you
why else would you do it
this is love doesn't pay the bills right
I mean it's not love's not gonna put me
in a car love's not gonna put me in in
the house on the hill
um money will though so
you out here husband shopping I would
think that you'd want to go for the one
with the biggest wallet
[Music]
yeah I don't know um the only
relationships that mean anything to me
in life anymore the relationships I have
with my children that's it
that's it and I continue to do this to
make sure that I can
you know put something back for them and
make sure that I can send them something
and you know just to prepare I've got a
daughter that's 14 about to be 15 so
it's almost time to get a car
you know so I've been putting back for
her car
for about six months now
I want to make sure she's got something
new and safe and
I know her dad he's married now and has
a baby with another woman so you know
now he's up to four kids and he's not
gonna be able to do that for her working
in a warehouse and his wife sits at home
doing the stay-at-home mom thing like
that there's no way
[Music]
what advice would you give to a young
woman who's considering doing this line
of work
if you're at any if you're at all soft
or have feelings at all don't just don't
don't because it'll change you it'll
ruin you
like I said you know you once you once
you're in this life it's real hard to to
to make any kind of worthwhile
connection with anybody
really it's like you ever play The Sims
like The Sims games you know people walk
around they've got the little spinning
Diamond over their head
um
it's like that for me it's like I walk
outside and I just see people and they
have dollar signs
is it going to be impossible for you to
ever separate money from Love from sex
I don't know that it'd be impossible but
I wouldn't know how to go about
separating the two because you're always
going to see yeah a guy as a financial
support right program right of some sort
yeah right a business arrangement
you know I'm sure somebody want to date
me we can date
but it's you better be funny to me it's
still just a business arrangement
I mean you know they're in it for love
that's more power to you it's still just
a bit it's a business arrangement to me
what's in your wallet
Tasha what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
in this life it's chess not Checkers you
know know your opponent and you gotta
plan your next move you constantly be
planning your next move
constantly
because you know you make the wrong next
move that could be your life
and that's I mean that's that's the the
reality of it you know at any moment
that could be your life
but like I said I'm just so used to it
and I've been in it so long like I
wouldn't I wouldn't know how to act
as a normal citizen out here
um
what's normal
this is normal to me this is this is my
normal
all right Tasha thank you so much for
sharing your story absolutely we see
lots of luck from hearing out